my name is Lauren Gaelic I am the
director of criminal justice reform at
The Reason Foundation which is the
nonprofit organization that publishes
Reason magazine and reason TV we wanted
to have this conversation you know
discuss the myths and the realities of
human trafficking in the United States
and as well in our opinion the misguided
ways in which governments are
approaching the issue and how you know
many of the ways that governments are
approaching this issue is actually
contrary to the criminal justice reform
that we've been hearing about and seeing
lately so anyway I want to introduce my
panelists first is Elizabeth Nolan Brown
she is a staff editor for reason.com
where she covers things like sex policy
criminal justice reproductive rights and
free speech her writing has also
appeared in places such as Politico
Playboy Time Newsweek Fox News the dish
libertarianism.org in the week she is
the author of the political magazine
article America's newest war which
discusses how legislators are making the
same mistakes with sex workers as they
did in combating the war on drugs so
next to her right is Katy Hale Jerris is
did I pronounce that right close enough
okay I get that with my last name too so
she is the research associate at
Georgetown University and a PhD
candidate in justice law and criminal
law criminology at American University
her research centers on the intersection
of criminal or otherwise socially
deviant behavior and public health
outcomes most of her much of her work
involves collaborations with
incarcerated communities sex workers and
harm reduction organizations she has
served as the Secretary of the sex
workers outreach projects national board
of directors for over two years during
her time with s swap us swap USA
she has spearheaded several advocacy
campaigns most recently organizing
the rest of 16 massage workers in
Honolulu Hawaii
the women were charged with sexual
assault directly related to their
interactions with the undercover
officers who arrested them she is also
currently serving as the lead editor of
the forthcoming not just the alleys
expanded perspective on Street based sex
work an edited volume that brings
researchers policymakers and people
impacted by street based sex work
together in conversation and then
finally we have Molly Gil
Mollie Gil is the government Affairs
Council for families against mandatory
minimums Pham is a nonprofit nonpartisan
sentencing reform organization founded
in 1991 and located in Washington DC as
government affairs counsel Gil works
with policymakers the media and the
public to advocate for sentencing laws
that are cost effective fit the crime
and the individual and protect
individual liberty and strengthen
families and communities Gil has
appeared as an expert on sentencing in
numerous print television and radio news
outlets and has been published in the
federal sentencing reporter she's also
serves as a commissioner on the District
of Columbia sentencing and criminal code
revision Commission prior to coming to
Pham in 2007 Gil practiced construction
and commercial litigation and assisted
with prosecuting homicides gang crimes
and gun offenses for the Hennepin County
Attorney's Office in Minneapolis
Minnesota
so please welcome okay so I'm going to
be a little tacky and kind of read off
of this sheet of paper to make sure that
I ask the questions that I want to ask
so please forgive me but before we get
started with kind of diving into the
subject I want to first make sure that
we're all on the same page as far as
these different terms are concerned
because I think that you know for a lot
of people in the audience they might not
be as up-to-date or have been following
these different pieces of legislation as
the panelists up here so I'm going to
ask Liz can you help differentiate
between the following terms
sex trafficking human trafficking labor
trafficking and sexual exploitation
sexual exploitation is just a broad term
that people use which can which
encompass a lot of things but human
trafficking is a term you often hear
when people are talking about this and
human trafficking encompasses both sex
trafficking and labor trafficking we're
gonna Bhosle be talking about sex
trafficking here tonight because that's
what a lot of the focus has been on with
the laws and the policing efforts and
sex trafficking is defined as you know
using force fraud or coercion to make
someone be engaged in prostitution if
they are an adult if they are under 18
it is sort of de facto defined as sex
trafficking so even if there is no force
fraud or coercion involved if someone is
in any way involved in a person under 18
selling sex then they are defined as a
trafficker so that's kind of yeah in the
broadest terms okay so the reason we're
kind of talking about this now is
because there's been a lot of media
attention on this issue you know just
last week I was on a flight to San Diego
and I switched to CNN and there was a
documentary on about human trafficking
narrated by Jada Pinkett Smith so just
kind of random but it just kind of shows
just how you know many celebrities when
celebrities are starting to get involved
in the cause that's when you gotta start
paying attention right so it just seems
like either this is a new phenomena or
there's been way more attention paid to
it then has been in recent years so
there's a lot of alarming statistics
that are out there that suggest that
this is a serious problem that needs to
be dealt with so I'm going to quote here
representative Joyce Bedi from Ohio
declared and she's a Democrat declared
in AM a statement that quote in the u.s.
some 300,000 children are at risk each
year for commercial sexual exploitation
and then similarly representative Anne
Wagner who's a Republican from Missouri
said at a congressional hearing she made
this a similar statement at a
congressional hearing and she claimed
that the stat came
from the Department of Justice the New
York Times has also attributed this
statistic to the Department of Justice
and Fox News has raised that number to
400,000 and has cited it came from a
Health and Human Services Department so
I wanted to ask Liz since you've written
on this issue before and there's her
political magazine piece is out in at
registration if you guys want to pick it
up you know can you highlight some of
the statistics that have been used to
justify these new laws and like where
are they coming from its are there and
is there any truth to them like just
talk about that for a little bit sure
and so there's yeah there's a lot of
really bad numbers out there floating
around and part of the problem is that
it's hard to find good numbers on things
that are black markets but it's also
that there are a lot of different
definitions of trafficking and the way
different countries the way different
states the way different counties to
find them it all contributes to an
inflating the statistics but the 300,000
number is one that's repeated all the
time or sometimes it'll see people say
hundreds of thousands of children are
being trafficked in the United States
and it's one of the most cited numbers I
see and Glenn Kessler at the Washington
Post sees their fact-checker columnist
he actually really did a good sort of
thorough debunking of that number in
particular recently where he you know
called all the different people who had
cited at all the different Congress
people and asked them where they got it
from and yeah they all cited DHS or FBI
so then he called them ultimately it was
none of them they traced it back to a
1991 study by a man named Richard st's
who it was a non peer-reviewed study and
he now disassociates himself from it he
says he doesn't want it like it's not a
good research study he doesn't be a part
of anymore there's a few years ago I
report came out from the crimes against
children Research Center it's a really
prestigious and sort of you know
nonpartisan research center that works
on these things and they said in all
capitals in their in their reports that
they put out please do nitesite these
numbers the reality is we do not know
how many juveniles are being involved in
prostitution credible numbers do not
exist so despite the fact that's
everywhere it's pretty much I mean sorry
also I just want to say that the at risk
the way he did this study was he came up
with a seer
of criteria such as if you were living
in public housing or if you were a
runaway or any number of things sort of
broad criteria like that and just assume
that those were things that put people
at risk of being trafficked so even
within this number it's just sort of a
broad guesstimate and yeah and if you
poked almost any of the numbers that
people are constantly citing out there
about sex trafficking you will kind of
come up with the same sort of thing I
just want to read you one more thing
about the State Department's numbers on
sex trafficking you also hear people
quote frequently but actually the
Government Accountability Office took a
look into them and they said that the
figures were questionable due to
methodological methodological weaknesses
gaps in data numerical discrepancies and
the fact that they were compiled by one
person who did not document his work so
this is kind of what we were looking at
here that wouldn't even survive like
college level standards of Yaak you'd
get kicked out of college for like
submitting a paper like Yeah right or
something like that
so and there's also just yeah so I think
that yeah okay um well despite all that
you know there has been this kind of
push for new legislation to kind of
target the issue of human trafficking
sex trafficking most recently you know
there was a federal piece of legislation
called the justice for victims of
trafficking Act passed with bipartisan
support and you know Molly I was just
hoping that you could explain some of
the new crimes that were created under
this piece of legislation and including
ones that pass or that include mandatory
minimums which you are all too familiar
with sure well Sam just for those who
aren't familiar fams nonpartisan
organization working on reforming
mandatory minimum sentencing laws for
those of you who think that has
something to do with the minimum wage
basically these are one-size-fits-all
sentencing laws if you commit X crime
you get at least Y number of years in
prison and judges aren't permitted to
consider any other facts of the case any
other mitigating circumstances there are
very few exceptions often to these laws
and sometimes no exceptions at all so
over 200 mandatory minimum sentencing
laws exist in the federal code and they
do tend to increase so that we've been
working against those laws not because
we think everything bad should be legal
but because we think that judges are in
the best position to judge individual
defendants and determine what the
appropriate punishment is in every case
and because we sort of fundamentally
believe that one-size-fits-all
government policies usually tend to not
fit a lot of people and produce a lot of
absurd circumstances and consequences
that can be very harmful and also very
expensive so we have been keeping an eye
on the the sex trafficking the bill that
passed this year was s 178 the justice
for victims of trafficking Act and it
actually took an existing mandatory
minimum sentencing law and expanded the
conduct and the existing law was
basically for sex trafficking and this
included as Liz defined it this included
both trafficking that involved force or
coercion of a victim as well as of an
adult victim as well as any sexual
conduct with a person under the age of
18 which is considered to sort of be de
facto coercive sexual behavior so this
law there was already a this was already
illegal under the federal law it had
been illegal since 2000 which with the
passage of the trafficking for the TVPA
which I can never remember actually
Victims Protection Act thank you so that
so it had already been a crime for a
very long period of time
the original mandatory minimums were
created in 2006 in a set of sort of very
bad circumstances involving several very
high-profile sex cases and and rape
cases that resulted in death that
received huge headlines across the
country this year Congress revisited
that statute and decided to add three
offenses
and one of those is soliciting a victim
of trafficking patronizing a victim of
trafficking or advertising a victim of
trafficking and these were problematic
to us because on principle we oppose all
mandatory minimums even for the worst
crimes we think even when the crime is
an unthinkable one there will always be
some circumstance we didn't think of and
we shouldn't have a one-size-fits-all
approach to it so we wrote a letter to
Congress and we raised several concerns
and ultimately Congress passed it anyway
it passed 99 zip in the Senate and over
in the house passed with only three no
votes which were very courageous one was
Bobby Scott a Democrat from Virginia he
liked us opposes all mandatory minimum
sentences on principle one was Thomas
Massie Republican from Kentucky and I
think probably has a pretty mean
libertarian streak in him and and then
the third one was John Conyers the
Democrat from Michigan and we praised
their vote there no vote against the
expanded mandatory minimum and you know
essentially the arguments we raised were
were that you know number one the terms
solicit and patronize were not defined
in the statute when there are 10 and 15
year mandatory minimums and you're gonna
take a decade of someone's life I think
you should be a little bit clearer about
what you mean I for one wrote in the
letter I said I'm a lawyer and I can't
tell you what patronize means I you know
I can think up a list of things it might
mean but I don't know for sure and you
don't tell me in the statute and then
the advertising mandatory minimum was
also disturbing because you you had to
knowingly you have to know that you were
advertising a traffic to person but
there were a lot of situations where
perhaps you could be talking about
someone who is very tangentially
connected at all with the activity in
question
we also sort of raised the question of
do you really want the IT guy to get the
same tenure mandatory minimum as the guy
who's you know flying to Thailand
kidnapping women bringing them back to
the United States keeping them in a
basement forcing them to be sex slaves
maybe maybe we don't we can have a
debate about that but those were some of
the objections we raised and as I said
the the expansions to the mandatory
minimums did pass okay so while this law
you know was passed the federal level
there have been new laws against human
trafficking all over the place some you
know as we just talked about the jbt a
there's numbers and states and so I kind
of wanted to ask Liz like can you tell
us about how these new laws differ from
laws that have been previously on the
books at both the state and federal
level or if you just want to talk about
the federal level or just you know
because I think it's confusing sometimes
for people when they hear about these
new laws against human trafficking sex
trafficking I mean Molly really did a
good job of laying out all of sort of
the problems with the jbt a but people
you know they don't understand like well
there's these new laws against human
trafficking like that must mean that
there were never any laws against human
trafficking before I mean as someone
who's not familiar with how the
government works which is you know a
little inefficiently like can you just
explain how you know what has happened
over the past couple years so I just
want to say that even before the the
first major trafficking Act passed in
2000 people could the government could
go after this sort of conduct at the
state and federal level I'm at the
federal level using the Mann Act which
prevents which bars transporting anyone
over state lines for prostitution
the tariff acts which prevents using
goods made from in indentured labor or
forced labor various other statutes
against indentured servitude kidnapping
abduction slavery child sexual abuse
statutory rape pandering those are all
laws on federal and state levels so
those laws were all used to prosecute
the conduct that we are talking about in
2000 the trafficking Victims Protection
Act was passed and I just I just wanna
give you guys a brief history of how
this has gone so it was passed
establishing these as specific crimes on
their own in 2000 and it also set up an
office to combat human trafficking at
that time
and expanded the penalties or set the
penalty ranges for these crimes in its
2003 authorization it up to the minimum
penalties and maximum penalties it
allowed for federal wiretapping to be
used to prosecute human traffickers and
it instituted a two strikes you're out
rule requiring the mandatory life
imprisonment upon a second sex offense
involving a minor unless the death
penalty as opposed the next three
authorization allowed unused federal
racketeering laws to go after
traffickers and to do asset forfeiture
for traffickers it added that people had
to reduce demand for commercial sex acts
which is the patrons of people that are
prostitution that that should be part of
federal anti-trafficking SATs policy and
it increased the funding sometimes by
two and three fold for fighting persons
who engage in the purchase of commercial
sex acts the next addition further
expanded the penalties and further
expanded the crimes including
obstructing a trafficking investigation
that were counted as sex trafficking and
further doubled the appropriations and
the last in a Thurs asian
reauthorization before this most recent
law passed set up increased federal task
forces to work on this and yeah so as
you can see though we have been sort of
steadily ramping up the penalties for
this for about 15 years now and that's
just at the federal level the states
have been doing the same thing in 2014
33 states passed new anti trafficking
laws in this year alone so far at least
22 have some of the trends that they
have been doing have been because like I
said oh maybe I didn't say but all 50
states have balls against human
trafficking on the books already so the
things they're passing now are things
like increasing the penalties adding in
mandatory minimums sometimes add adding
aggravating factors where if you know it
takes place in certain distance of a
school or whatever then it's a it's a
bigger crime a lot of states are adding
giving police wiretapping capabilities
giving them grand juries a one-state
just possible grand juries can prosecute
these cases so they're adding a lot of
new ways that police can go after this
they're also adding a lot of things
where
people who are charged with trafficking
can have their assets forfeited and and
this includes the things like she was
talking about like people who were
advertised and so it's kind of a broad
range of contact that's in any way
associated can then be subject to civil
asset forfeiture for this and then one
of the other some of the other big
things that the states have been doing
to our increased adding any sex
trafficking crimes to lists for which
offenders have to apply and register on
the sex offender list and crack adding
more penalties for people who solicit
prostitution which is you know kind of
what people call John's sometimes on the
clients of prostitution and a lot of
this doesn't really matter if the the
client knows that the person is
trafficked or not or knows the victims
age so they're sort of adding them now
if you offer to pay for sex then you are
accounted in this category of sex
traffickers in a lot of these new state
laws 21 States us so far have passed
those sort of laws so that's sort of
where we've been heading I think there's
a lot of idea that people yeah that
these things are not criminalized but
really they they have are criminalized
they've been criminalized for years and
we just keep ramping up the penalties
and the prosecutorial power that we are
giving people to go after them okay so
now I have a question for you finally
Katie you know now that we've kind of
laid the groundwork and seen how these
crimes have come about how these
penalties for these crimes have been
ramped up over the past several decades
I kind of want to ask you a question
about how you know how does the focus on
increasing policing of sex trafficking
affect adults who are choosing to work
in the sex industry you know people who
are engaged in consensual sale of their
bodies version sex yeah so I want to
share just a couple stories we've been
throwing a lot of facts at you and I
think that putting kind of some personal
faces on this would be helpful the first
way that has been most recently featured
in the news is MasterCard and Visa
coming out and saying that they will no
longer allow their credit cards to be
used to place ads on Backpage so instead
now sex workers you have to use Bitcoin
to place ads on Backpage which
created a fantastic number of great
YouTube videos about how to use a
Bitcoin for sex workers so if you search
these they're really really great I
highly recommend it but what this is
done you explained back page first yeah
those who don't know
so back page is just it's it's really
like Craigslist but very geared towards
adult ads so they're not even
necessarily prostitution but would
include escorting massage all kind of
ranges back page who we at swap just
love them recently responded to this by
saying well guess what we're just gonna
make all adult ads free for the next six
months so kind of I'm not sure if I'm
allowed to swear but like screw you
Chicago it's great you Chicago um
because that's the where the sheriff who
introduced this was from Chicago so
that's kind of what has happened on a
very large scale um you and your
introduction mentioned the the sixteen
women who were arrested for massage and
Honolulu this is also something we're
seeing increasingly on a state-by-state
level is that women are being not just
women but but people more broadly are
being arrested on sex work charges and
then have these charges amplified to
sexual assault so while there's kind of
this prevailing discourse of now looking
at people engaged in sex work and I'll
get back to talking about that term in
just a minute they're originally being
charged with sexual assault and just to
clarify the sexual assault that they
were charged with with sexual assault
against the undercover officers who were
soliciting massage from in order to bust
them for prostitution
so I said was in order to save them from
sex right and I think it was the like
underlying premise there and so all of
these women then were brought to the
police station charged with sex sexual
assault three which includes mandatory
sex offender registration as well as
present
and we're told well we are really
interesting and going after your
trafficker if you could tell us who your
trafficker is we'll make sure that
you're hooked up with appropriate
services the problem is that those
appropriate services when we've looked
at that more closely just simply don't
exist and the best example of this is in
New York City they instituted a human
trafficking court very similar to a drug
court where now everyone who is arrested
for prostitution because again you're
starting to see this blurring of lines
between anything that is differentiated
from sex trafficking to sex work it's
brought into court on a certain day and
said okay you can either go through the
problem-solving court or you can ask for
a trial if you go through the human
trafficking court you're sentenced to
treatment which includes anything from
yoga sessions to individual counseling
and there isn't really no there's no
evaluation that's done it just happens
to be like what treatment is being
featured that day the red umbrella
project in New York did a fascinating
huge report on this and I highly
recommend that everyone go home and read
it what they also found is that there
were very limited resources for
individuals who spoke a language other
than English and in fact the only
resource for individuals who is speaking
a either Cantonese or Mandarin was
actually a church based group so they
had to go through a church based group
in order to receive their court-ordered
treatment in the last story that I
wanted to tell kind of to conclude my
parade of Horrors here on how this has
affected people it is a case out of
Alaska that features a woman named amber
bat amber bat was running a escort
business out of her home she had about
32 different women who had signed
independent contractor clauses who were
working for her she maintained a website
and acted acted as a facilitator so
people would call her lines she would
say okay
who are you interested in seeing tonight
she would make the arrangement she would
also put up front the money for hotels
all those sorts of things she had all
these on file and as
results she also got a share of the
profits she was and she ended up being
charged under trafficking and is one of
the listed people she was charged with
trafficking herself because she actually
was engaging in sex work herself and so
we're starting to see this now that
people who are engaging in sex work who
don't have an obvious pimp or trafficker
are also being charged themselves the
the thing that I also want to add is
that in in amber batts case she was also
paying for for background checks on all
800 of the clients that she had on her
books so she was conducting extensive
vetting of these individuals that III
want to add that point because doing
this type of bedding is very very
expensive and often is an additional
cost it's very hard to vet clients and
she was doing that if you were if you
were an independent contractor for her
and so you're the fee was it was
including those services now you know
now she has been arrested she just
agreed to a plea deal where she'll serve
four to seven years in prison and has
already paid fifteen thousand dollars
she faces more fines as well as
registration on the sex offender
registry once she is released from
prison so I'm really glad that you
brought some of that up because as I was
talking about the increased penalties I
know that that can kind of sound like
well who cares if we're talking about
people like the person she the
mythological person who's you know like
sex trafficking people from Thailand and
keeping them in his basement but the
people that are actually targeted under
these laws are a lot of people like she
has mentioned and sex workers talk a lot
about how you know any one of them who
help each other can be charged as a
trafficker I've actually and this one of
the craziest things I've noticed this
summer is you know as we've said anyone
under 18 is defined as a de-facto
trafficking victim even if they don't
have a pimp even if there's no force
they're defined as they cannot consent
we've seen a few cases recently of
federal trafficking charges against
teenagers who have driven there who are
sex workers who have driven their other
teenagers to jobs or recruited them to
work with them so we have 17 year-olds
being charged as sex traffickers for
recruiting 17 year old friends to work
with them and
you know these are the people that are
sometimes prosecuted under these laws so
and um and I I just would like to add to
that you had mentioned earlier that we
we don't have good research around youth
engaged in sex work that's actually not
true anymore we do and the Department of
Justice actually funded it they funded
it under a provision to fund anti
trafficking research the problem was
that it didn't find what they wanted it
to find so I want to make a huge shout
out here to Ric Curtis I like uni SUNY
when one of one of the Moonies who did
this research and actually interviewed
294 Street involved youth who were gay
engaging in commercial sex work and I
wrote the numbers down so I'm because I
wanted to be absolutely sure that I got
them right they interviewed 294
individuals who are engaged in street
based sex work at a commercial level who
are under the age of 18 and what they
found is that the vast majority over
half were recruited by friends not by a
pimp or trafficker in fact just 19% of
the total sample said that they had been
recruited by a pimp or trafficker in the
majority of those individuals were no
longer working for that person when
asked who is actually working for a pimp
or a market facilitator at the time that
number group actually was 14 percent for
women three percent for four men our
boys in zero percent of trans youth who
were who were who they interviewed so
what I want to stress is when we think
of sex work we often talk about it in
sex worker rights as being on this
continuum with kind of a small group of
individuals who are really engaging and
choice like sex work by choice on one
side sex work by coercion on the other
but the majority of people really fall
in this middle area this gray area of
being there because of circumstance
because of lack of employment
opportunities because of transphobia
because of homelessness because of
involvement in the foster care system
even among youth and when we divert so
many resources to addressing that small
group who is in sex
sex work or being sexually exploited we
are really just ignoring everyone in the
middle and in yeah I'll conclude my my
monologuing there yeah it was great
Molly so I want to I want to ask you a
question because you've been working for
fam for a while and you've seen all
sorts of new mandatory minimum either
suggestions pop up or actual laws passed
in a number of states and at the federal
level so it's sadly sort of become a
routine for you at this point so I kind
of I just wanted to ask and just get
your insight into how how did these
mandatory minimums come about why do why
are we always seeing new mandatory
minimums proposed why does that happen
well I'm glad we have alcohol in the
building because this makes a great
drinking game actually not even joking
not that I'm incur if you're underage
and I'm not encouraging you to drink so
at our website we have a complete list
of all the federal mandatory minimum
sentences if you ever want that time
reading this is also a fantastic
resource although some of this stuff is
just really fun and we have the we we
have the statute listed and then the
crime and then the year it was created
and pretty much uniformly if you go
through this list you can decide what
you can figure out why the mandatory
minimum was created based on the date
that it was created so we'll just we'll
just play a couple and maybe I'll have
to get your shots afterwards
okay so 1986 we have the creation of our
federal mandatory minimum drug
sentencing laws any guesses as to the
historical event that precipitated the
creation of those war on drugs you
children of the 80s come on get with me
here
so 1986 we have a very famous college
basketball student named Len Bias who
goes out he overdoses on powder cocaine
when he's drafted and is out partying
and celebrating he overdoses he dies it
makes national headlines the next
morning senator Tip O'Neill huge Boston
Celtics fan
is devastated that he will no longer be
a Celtic and flies down to Washington DC
gets on the floor of Congress and a few
months before an election says we need
to crack down on this horrible crack
cocaine that is killing our children and
this horrible drug epidemic that we have
going on in America
voila October 27th 1986 very
suspiciously close to an election day
Congress passes our mandatory minimum
drug sentencing laws which we still have
30 years later today
some some more fun ones in here 1934
creation of a ten-year mandatory minimum
for causing death while fleeing a bank
robbery and takers on this one 1934
Bonnie and Clyde had their crime spree
so it works every single time 1964 we
create a mandatory minimum for
assassinating a president real
deterrence there these these ones are
really fun these are some of my
favorites 1790 piracy on the high seas
when we were a small fledgling country
we had a serious problem with the
Barbary pirates and the Congress decided
they were going to take this seriously
and create mandatory minimums for these
for piracy so those are some of our
oldest mandatory minimum sentencing laws
and I you know I talked about the you
know 2006 was the year that we created
our mandatory minimums for human sex
trafficking that was a terrible year
there were several as I mentioned very
high-profile headline-grabbing deaths of
young women who had been sexually
assaulted and killed I remember it very
memorable because at the time I was
working in a prosecutor's office in
Minneapolis and one of those deaths was
a woman named Roush adine I was 24 drew
she Dean was 22 it's basically sort of
every parent's horror story Jerusha Dean
was kidnapped from a parking lot by a
registered sex offender taken out raped
killed he ultimately her her body was
found and they discovered who had killed
her there was a lot of talk in in the
prosecute
office I was working in as to whether
Minnesota would prosecute it or North
Dakota would ultimately it became a
federal case because they wanted to
apply the death penalty to him and
that's exactly what happened and so part
of the Adam Walsh Child Protection Act
which created the mandatory minimums for
this crime included a provision called
Drew's law anytime you have Bobby Scott
a Democrat from Virginia will often say
this anytime you have a law with a
victims that begins with the victims
name if you're a member of Congress you
better not vote against that law we are
actually seeing this day I have a
modern-day example that is happening as
we speak there's now a Kate's law effort
in Congress this is stemming from the
tragic death of Kate Steinle in San
Francisco not too long ago by a person
who was in the country illegally and
there there are three there are three
bills that would do this they would
create a five-year mandatory minimum for
illegal reentry T V United States again
these they these bills were introduced
without hearings without testimony
without any kind of look at the evidence
or data or the effectiveness of our
illegal reentry laws and there's
basically a huge political wind behind
the back of this effort and of course
fam is opposing it because we think that
we need to take smarter approaches that
have individualized justice so I guess
this will be my final question before we
open it up to Q&A but I we've spent a
lot of time talking about the unintended
consequences on you know legal sex not
legal but consenting adults sex workers
and talking about the unattended
consequences of mandatory minimum
sentences in general but I just wanted
to ask maybe Katie or anybody else who
wants to answer you know are some of
these laws that are being passed are
they helping sex trafficking actual
victims of sex trafficking because I
want to reiterate that we are not saying
that human trafficking isn't an issue it
is it does happen and so I want to ask
you guys do some of these laws actually
harm
sex trafficking victims do they help
them what kind of effect do they have on
real victims of sex trafficking um I I
would say that from an evidence-based
perspective we simply have no evidence
showing that these laws are helping at
this point which is is problematic in
and of itself they've been on the books
at this point long enough that we should
at least have some evidence and what we
do have suggests that there is no
difference for individuals who go
through these programs versus those who
who are who are arrested and go through
prison which suggests that they're and
they're certainly not helping what we
know just from stories of swap members
is that being in these programs can
actually lead to more consequences and
I'll leave you just with a story that
Rick Curtis and his research team again
found which was that of young girls who
did have a pimp what they found is that
a large number of them actually were
recruited by their pimp from a program
such as this so that traffickers that do
exist in the very scary way that we
think of traffickers are aware of these
programs and and actually are using them
to identify people who are vulnerable
which i think is is probably the biggest
argument against using them I just I
just want to say that you know a shared
Hope International which is one of the
big anti trafficking organizations they
did a study looking at police stings to
try and catch people who were buying sex
and they found that's almost half of
them involved no actual victims so all
most of the sex trafficking things that
they were convicted doing involve no
victims they just involved police who
pretended to be an adult sex worker once
a man agreed to meet them they said
actually I'm underage the man still came
they arrested them this is what we have
a lot of our police resources going to
and 50 to 60 percent of these things are
conducted like that in it was in select
cities but I mean this is happening
and a lot of them meanwhile if you talk
to people who are working really closely
with victims of sex trafficking or or
maybe just people who are in sex work
but do not totally want to be there the
biggest thing stopping them from either
getting out of prostitution or from
escaping people who are forcing them
into it is that they just don't have
anywhere to go and they don't have any
resources they don't there are nowhere
near enough emergency beds at shelters
there are police do not take them
seriously when they come they try to
arrest them for prostitution instead you
know they go to court and they want to
get help finding a job and they send
them to yoga classes so I think that in
the in the way that we are diverting all
of these resources to this sort of super
intense law enforcement Law & Order
crime aspect we're really neglecting
like the things that are very important
for actually helping victims okay and
with that I guess we will conclude the
discussion aspect of this so I want to
give our panelists a round of applause
if we can